[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi est 17
mai la fin des travaux de réhabilitation
énergétique à trappes pour 85 logements
l'isolation thermique de la résidence
renault arrêté porté par le bailleur
social indépendant logirep
l'inauguration des logements s'est faite
aujourd'hui en présence de personnalités
politiques locales
c'est une première depuis longtemps en
ile-de-france un vignoble vient d'être
lancée à d'avron dans les yvelines le
projet porté par trois jeunes
entrepreneurs qui ont planté pour
débuter 6000 pieds sur 3 ha et puis à
voisins le bretonneux la semaine du
développement durable se poursuit cet
après-midi un atelier jardinage pour
tous étaient proposés près de l'espace
de covile l'occasion de se rappeler ou
de découvrir aussi quelques astuces
avant de se remettre à jardiner l'enjeu
est environnemental mais aussi
économique les travaux pour la
réhabilitation énergétique de 85
logements sociaux dont la résidence
renoir attrape viennent de s'achever
coût de l'opération 5 millions d'euros
le bâtiment est désormais recouvert
d'une enveloppe isolante une visite des
lieux était organisée aujourd'hui en
présence notamment du maire socialiste
de la ville à guy malandain reportage de
stéphane servant et mélina correia
c'était ce matin la fin d'un chantier de
réhabilitation de 85 logements sociaux
attrape une réalisation qui s'inscrit
dans un grand projet de rénovation
urbaine de la ville un certain
rue où deux chemins piétons kif qui font
que les grand îlot qui avait été conçu
dans les années 70 80 soit morcelé si je
te dis entreprises lyon qui permettent
sans doute pas aux gens d'accéder
d'avoir une adresse
et puis qui permet aussi aux services de
secours aux services de sécurité au
service d'entretien d'avoir des accès
beaucoup plus facile ce chantier et
innovants à plus d'un titre et a été
plusieurs fois primé installation de
panneaux voltaïques et solaire isolation
thermique par des éléments de façade en
bois chauffage collectif au gaz
tout a été conçu pour réduire les
consommations d'énergie as un bon
exemple de ce qu'on peut faire c'est
innovant c'est c'est raisonnable en
termes de coût et en qualité de vie à
l'intérieur d'une habitation s'est
séparé en positif les logements et les
parties communes ont pu également
bénéficier de petits travaux de
réfection les locataires ont pu rester
chez eux pendant tous les travaux elles
ont fait ravalement et de la cuisine les
toilettes puis les la salle de bain des
matériaux de qualité avec l'utilisation
du bois des délais raccourcis un coût
maîtrisé et une résidence capable de
produire une partie de son énergie
un exemple qui devrait servir de modèle
pour les nombreux projets de
réhabilitation en attente dans la région
en 2020 il sera possible de déguster du
chardonnay du merlot ou encore du pinot
noir 100% franciliens c'est une première
à d'avron dans les yvelines plus de 16
mille pieds de vignes ont été plantées
hier sur 3 ha reportage de wilfrid
errishi sur des images de nos confrères
livre une première
un sous-sol calcaire et un vent léger à
quelques 100 mètres d'altitude sur ce
plateau à d'avron les conditions
semble-t-il et à la maturation des
raisins et donc à l'obtention d'un vin
de grande qualité
on plante du chardonnay du chemin en
blanc et en plantes du merlot et du
pinot noir en rouge
donc c'est des choix de ces pages qu'on
a fait en fonction des potentiels de
maturité qui a ici en fonction du climat
fonction des sols aussi on a fait des
choix de cépage pour certains qui sont
habituellement cultiver un peu plus au
sud
et on souhaite faire un pari d'avenir en
les amenant un peu plus au nord pour les
amener en limite de maturité âgés de 27
à 31 ans julien bru style c'est julien
bengué et adrien pélissier sont les
trois fondateurs de la winery parisienne
ce sont eux qui ont eu l'idée
d'installer dans les yvelines le premier
vignoble professionnels d'ile-de-france
un vignoble de 16 mille pieds l'objectif
commercial c2c de pouvoir faire
découvrir localement ses 20 ans les
rendre abordable au plus grand nombre
donc pour la distribuer aux filières
courtes et en circuit court pour que les
yvelinois puissent profiter du fruit de
leur terroir le département soutient
l'initiative pour son président
l'objectif est aussi de renforcer le
caractère rural des yvelines ne pensais
pas qu'on pouvait très honnêtement faire
du vin à des fins commerciales dans le
département des yvelines et le
réchauffement climatique
l'imagination de ces jeunes gens
maintenant convaincus et donc oui on
fait le pari avec eux et je suis
convaincu que ce serait un pari gagnant
les premières vendanges sont attendus
pour 2020 si l'essai est concluant
l'exploitation pourrait atteindre les 26
hectares
vous les avez sûrement remarqué si vous
empruntez les transports en commun à la
gare de montigny le bretonneux des
travaux ont débuté depuis lundi sur
l'avenue du centre ils devraient durer
cinq semaines et vont permettre
notamment le remplacement des dalles du
trottoir par un revêtement en asphalte
ou encore la création d'une place de
stationnement pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
coût des travaux cent mille euros
totalement à la charge de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle souhaite interpeller les politiques
et à quelques jours maintenant des
élections législatives la fédération du
bâtiment yvelines organise ce mercredi
soir à trappes une réunion autour de ses
112 propositions pour reconstruire la
france une soirée pour débattre avec les
représentants l'eau
des républicains du ps dans marche ou
encore du front national mais alors
quels sont les enjeux dans ce secteur
nicolas d'andré a rencontré un chef
d'entreprise en bâtiment écouter on
m'appelle fabrice martinez
j'ai 51 ans que j'habite à voisins le
bretonneux et je travaille dans
l'entreprise locale de 550 un bâtiment
et je suis chef d'equipe on travaille
huit heures par jour et ont fait 39
heures dans la semaine
bon salaire c'est 2
2000 euros par mois alors pour les
présidentielles j'ai voté la france
insoumise qu'ils correspondent beaucoup
plus là on les idées et pour les
législatives
je ferai de même pour cette législative
sur une attente qu'on parle d'eux
les retraites les pouvoirs d'achat et
des salaires et au niveau des emplois
une paye énormément de taxes ce qui fait
que le salaire augmente quasiment pas le
pouvoir d'achat est assez réduit depuis
plusieurs années je suis plus en attente
sur
la france un sony qui propose des choses
le concrète la flexibilité apporte des
petits boulots fait payer avec une
amplitude horaire extrêmement large
ce qui fait que après la vie privée il
reste plus beaucoup d'heures à passer au
confié et ça c'est très franchement très
mauvais sans transition à voisins le
bretonneux les habitants ont pu profiter
aujourd'hui du beau temps avec un
atelier jardinage près de l'espace de
covile petits et grands ont ainsi
participé à différents ateliers et aussi
noté quelques conseils des agents du
service espaces verts de la ville un
reportage sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
alors à quoi ça peut bien servir après
midi pédagogique et ludique au jardin
jeanne fleuret création d'un refuge pour
insectes atelier potager ou encore
massif floral de nombreuses animations
étaient proposées pour les enfants en ce
mercredi ensoleillé des enfants et
quelques adultes curieux également pour
avoir des petits conseils des petites
astuces pour le
mon petit bout de jardin j'ai à la
maison on avait vu qu'il y avait la
semaine
oui mais pas mal de choses à avoir ça
donc on s'est dit tiens on va les voir
les jardiniers on le voit souvent dans
la ville voilà pour avoir des conseils
pour la maison inscrit dans le cadre de
la semaine du développement durable ces
ateliers sont également l'occasion pour
les agents de la ville de partager leurs
connaissances et leur savoir faire
les gens nous voient nous demande
beaucoup de conseils constamment très
souvent nous sollicite donc là ça permet
de répondre de temps en temps aux
attentes de chacun pas où on essaie de
transmettre
et puis effectivement de partager quoi
c'est le but de l'opération également à
transmettre et partager c'est aussi
l'idée de l'opération quand même
dimanche marquera la fin de la semaine
du développement durable à voisins le
bretonneux
d'ici là d'autres animations vous
permettront de récolter des informations
précieuses avant de vous mettre à
jardiner hameau de sport à présent et de
golf plus précisément à 500 jours de la
ryder cup 2018 qui se tiendra sur les
greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'organisation
vient de choisir son ambassadeur et
c'est le navigateur armel le cléac'h qui
a été sélectionné pour incarner cette
fonction symbolique on écoute
à ce propos la réaction du dernier
vainqueur du vendée globe une fierté à
notre ambassadeur pour la ryder cup en
france l'année prochaine on a besoin en
france d'avoir des compétitions comme ça
de deux niveaux
mondiale ne renommée internationale pour
justement donné des vocations
des jeunes des moins jeunes pour jouer
au golf parce que on se rend compte que
effectivement c'est un sport que l'on
peut pratiquer à tous niveaux
en boxe marvin petit s'apprête demain à
combattre pour le match le plus
important probablement de sa carrière le
sportif élan courtois double champion de
france va défier au cirque d'hiver de
paris l'espagnol gerber santana pour la
ceinture de l'union européenne le combat
était initialement prévu en janvier
dernier mais l'ibérique avait dû annuler
le combat deux jours avant l'événement
on écoute le boxeur au micro de notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros c'est bon c'est un très bon
boxeur je ne sous estime pas le mot book
sorte jamais sous estimer un bosseur
mais il va en arrivant du moins quand
même parce que je suis prêt j'ai regardé
quelques vidéos
bon voilà c'est un bon technicien
après je pense que ça fera pas moi je
suis quelqu'un qui va ramasser tout le
temps je vais pas le lâcher
donc je vais
vous dit tout ce que j'ai vu la
différence c'est que j'ai
gros coeur c'est un gros mental et je
vais pas lâcher cette ceinture et là moi
à gerber juste quelque chose à dire
tiens toi prendre des vrais coups parce
que je tire ma chance j'ai un peu
d'ambiance quarante ans plus tard son
nom est toujours indissociable de
starmania
fabienne thibeault interpréter marie
jeanne la serveuse automate dans la
comédie musicale le 7 juin prochain elle
sera à rambouillet pour un concert
caritatif fois le chantera les plus
grands titres de l'époque starmania
mélanie poker a eu la chance de la
rencontrer reportage
[Musique]
ce soir je
combien
1978 la france découvre la voix de
fabienne thibeault à 26 ans elle et
marie jeanne dans starmania
près de quarante ans plus tard l'opéra
rock ne l'a pas quitté starmania
complètement fondatrice de même c'est à
partir de starmania que le puma phone
ma rencontre ma cheville
starmania et est un vraiment un
patrimoine de la culture populaire ni
calme c'est
beaucoup en tulle ci ont trait
extrêmement et fondateur de ce combiné
d'humour le 7 juin elle sera accompagnée
de cinq chanteurs ils mêleront titres
incontournables de la comédie musicale
les morceaux québécois une soirée
organisée avec le lion's club de
rambouillet la vie de la cité a montré
qu'il y avait ce problème de pour les
personnes isolées pour les personnes
dépendantes de trouver un délit q la
disposition pour pouvoir circuler pour
aller faire ses courses pour aller chez
le médecin il fallait demander à la
voisine et quand on a un problème de
personnes isolées
c'est difficile le club espère récolter
8500 euros lors de cette soirée pour que
ce titre de luc plamondon et michel
berger ne soit plus d'actualité
[Musique]
e
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur le site internet tv
fil 78 points comme ou l'application tv
fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]